il y avait un an tout pile mais c'est
sous nos yeux la plus grande révolution
télévisuelle de ces dernières décennies
le lancement en prime time de la toute
première émission de téléréalité de
france 11 célibataire coupé du monde
filmé dans un loft de 225 mètres carrés
24 heures sur 24 par 26 caméras des 50
micro avec love story m6 le savait elle
allait frapper un grand coup et c'est le
moins que l'on puisse dire en vingt ans
cette émission a fait changer à jamais
le visage de la télévision un casting
fort dont vingt ans après on se rappelle
sans mal contre hasbro la retraite au
delà de révéler jean-edouard loana ou
stevie l'émission a été aussi l'occasion
de découvrir pour la toute première fois
benjamin castaldi sur m6 c'est toute
cette époque un prime time diffusée le 8
avril prochain sur ces 8 va consacrer ce
soir vous saurez tout sur nos candidats
vous les découvrirez on découvrait
également tout ce qu'ils vont devoir
quitter ce soir les moments cultes de
cette émission phénomène de société qui
a été cette aventure dans sa l'auteur
comme christophe julie steevy sans
oublier loana le temps d'une soirée ils
vont revenir deux décennies plus tard
sur ce chapitre de l'histoire du paf
alors love story fête ses 20 ans sur ces
8 je matte
évidemment il n'ya que des ouï mais bon
moi je suis très content parce que non
seulement on va vous tous vous raconter
mais surtout l'envers du décor ils sont
presque tous là et nos feux ravageant
les doigts on a été vite
[Musique]
est ce qu'on n'a pas en fait on était
bien sûr des le fait de taper est ce qu
on a passé ses années ce qui fait un
métier maintenant qu'il n'empêche de
montpezat et l'or qui a laissé le génial
parce que moi tu m'a vraiment donné
envie d'avoir une piscine en regardant
mais surtout en deuxième partie
d'émission en eyed peas toutes les
questions que vous vous posez sur le
programme ou vous répondra à tous et
sans tricher les entrées de boue sans
filtre je suis curieux tiens
en bref béton bon franchement vous allez
étonné on va tout vous révéler à sa
christopher bon j'ai pas envie de faire
faillite et avec vous mais c'est vrai
qu'on le répète jamais assez que c'est
logique ça comment chaque jeudi 8 avril
à 21 heures qu'un jeune homme
non mais c'est vrai que love story ça a
tout inventé c'est dans l'esprit voilà
collectif de chacun c'est une marque
iconique c'est là où les prémices de la
télé réalité on pouvait suivre la vie
des candidats vainqueurs 24 7 jours sur
7 donc ça a tout inventé
et c'est vrai que ring pour voir
empreinte j'ai envie de deux ans fait la
civette ce qui va être très très fort au
delà du fait qu effectivement on les
avait presque tout cela c'est que nous
on vous connaît personnellement et on
sait que vous avez encore plein de trucs
à raconter sur les coulisses des
documentaires en vingt ans on a vu plein
mais là j'ai vraiment l'impression que
je vais apprendre des choses il ya au
moins cinq scoop on voit un 5 révélation
ne l'a jamais pas et l inverse de
christopher je fais pas ça pour eux pour
vous passer de la pommade vraiment j'ai
hyper hâte de savoir parce que j'ai
envie de les revoir l'autre jour quand
on quand on avait julie et christophe
j'étais comme une gamine parce que moi
j'avais 18 ans quand le loft a été
diffusée et j'avais la chaîne 24 heures
sur 24
oui j'essaie en passion totale donc là
j'ai vraiment envie d'apprendre des
choses donc franchement merci et en plus
la mort est quand même très qu'annoncé
criée qui est derrière le shabbat iwuy
german look on sait que ce sera génial
ab sur sept dit merci bayou mais j'ai
une question est ce qu'il y aura un
remake de la scène de la piscine
[Musique]
d'abord que vous puissiez nous donner
des nouvelles de loana parce que par
rapport au passé alors je vous dis le
jaunard le parti pris de la production
et de la chaîne d'ailleurs je vous le
dis c'est que loana sera là normalement
oui seulement si elle va valser
on est là pour célébrer les 20 ans on
est là pour diversité on met la peau
voilà on est là pour se rappeler de bons
moments des moments même si les moments
un peu mon à pleurer on est énervé
mais ces focus sur fil de l'oft voilà
c'est fait vous ne sais pas du tout à la
séance on en a beaucoup parlé
malin sera pas le propos oui j'étais
assez feelgood moi je me rappelle de la
première il y avait ce souvenir
d'excitation de voir les premières
images et c'est je crois la première
émission où tu avais des premiers
personnages de télévision en réel auquel
tu pouvais vraiment identifié et je
trouve cela avant mais pas de démission
où les candidats était aussi mise en
avant valeur à part les fictions mais la
soupe il ya eu un avant et humain qu'on
aménage une question à vous poser est ce
qu'on est encore nostalgique de cette
époque
non je n'ai pas du tout nostalgie j'ai
vu très content d'avoir fait d'ailleurs
siens dans les révélations et dans le
gros scoop que vous aurez le 8 avril
je vous dirai pourquoi il n'y a jamais
eu de saison 3 allez